der muezzin ruf in deutschland mitten in
köln die oberbürgermeisterin henriette
reker die sagt das ist ein zeichen des
respekts ist es dass das kann man so und
so sehen ich fand es bemerkenswert am
statement von frau reker dass sie zwar
auf der einen seite sagt es ist nur ein
modellprojekt und dann aber erklärt
warum das einzig und allein die richtige
entscheidung ist den muezzin rufe hallen
zu lassen und werde damit ein problem
hat der kann sich gar kollegen im
prinzip hat sie natürlich nicht
wortwörtlich so gesagt aber kritik hat
sie sofort beiseite geschoben und ich
finde an der ganzen argumentation einige
sachen etwas schwierig also zum einen
der vergleich dass der kirchenglocke mit
dem multi move also ich glaube das
einzige was diese beiden miteinander
gemeinsam haben ist dass es sich dabei
um geräusche handelt ansonsten war es
dass eine kirchenglocke ist das eine das
ist was sein mechanisches auf der
anderen seite ist dass der ruf des
muezzin das ist also ein mann der in ein
megafon schreit und sagt allah akbar
gott ist groß und es gibt keinen anderen
gott außer allah das hört sich sehr
unterschiedlich an und das ist auch sehr
unterschiedlich gemeint also wird direkt
ein exklusivitätsanspruch
aufgestellt es gibt nur den einen gott
und das ist unser gott kommt in die
moschee beten und ich glaube wenn man
von vielfalt und respekt spricht er geht
es ja nicht darum alles was es auf der
welt gibt sofort zu erlauben und in
unseren alltag zu integrieren sondern es
geht ja darum dass auch das was man in
unseren alltag holt das auch das für
vielfalt und respekt steht und gerade
bei ditib moscheen kann man da glaube
ich da muss man auch kein fragezeichen
setzen was ich gerade sagen wollte da
ist kann man eigentlich sagen vielfalt
und respekt gibt es dort nicht zumindest
nicht für andersdenkende du hast es
angesprochen 2018 wurde diese
ditib-moschee eingeweiht zur einweihung
kam erdogan erdogan ist eine des
schlimmsten islamistischen
antisemitischen hetze die wir gerade
kennen wenn man sich anschaut was dieser
mensch über israel und über juden sagt
das möchte ich ehrlich gesagt ungerne
hier in deutschland haben ich finde er
ist schon problematisch dass türkisches
geld in moscheen in deutschland fließt
das da entschieden wird was dort
gepredigt was dort gelehrt wird und dass
man jetzt einseitig das einfach
anerkennt und sagt doch ihr dazu und
damit meine ich nicht ihr muslime
sondern ihre moschee verbände und beruf
das kann jetzt auch freitags erscheint
das ist finde ich sehr einseitige
anerkennung und das ist auch glaube ich
dass was viele menschen stören wird dass
unser staat unsere gesellschaft sehr gut
darin ist mehr zuzulassen aber auch
nicht manchmal die notwendigen roten
linien zu ziehen das haben wir gerade in
nrw gesehen wo die ditib auch rein
geholt wird in den schulunterricht und
ich glaube dass statt viele menschen
[Musik]